breast cancer drugs fail miserably in
phase 2 clinical trials one of the
reasons being that the modeling that's
done in the beginning to test these
drugs is not very useful our research
has shown that the human immune system
is incredibly important in synergizing
with cancer therapy to kill Uman tumors
human breast tumors especially so what
our model does is it takes into account
the human immune system in testing new
cancer drugs and we believe that this is
the missing link
before I became affiliated with women's
health research at Yale I was doing very
basic cancer research and then this idea
popped into my mind in a conversation
with a few of my colleagues about
developing a humanized model of breast
cancer so in this model we were able to
produce the human immune system in mice
and then study breast cancer and its
treatment on top of that human immune
system our most important finding is
that radiation and the end the human
immune system work together to kill
cancer cells and this is really
important because the development of
this humanized model of breast cancer
will enable us to test novel drugs that
can be used to treat cancer better
our preliminary data showing that the
human immune system interacts with
radiation to kill tumor cells really got
one of our collaborators very interested
and she happens to be a breast surgeon
so she's going to supply us with breast
tumors from women who were in her clinic
right out of the operating room we can
take fragments of a woman's breast tumor
put them into a mouse that has her
immune system and then test novel drugs
and drugs that are currently operational
in the clinic on her breast tumor to see
which one's actually killed the tumor
and then she'll be able to be treated
with those drugs and I really feel like
this has a better chance of working than
anything else that's out there
without this critical funding this
critical pilot funding I wouldn't have
been able to carry out this research
develop the humanized model and many of
my colleagues would not be able to do
what they're doing in order to improve
the quality of life for women now we can
use those preliminary data funded by
women's health research at Yale to apply
for larger funding from the National
Institutes of Health and from larger
foundations in order to move the
research for it we think that this model
will enable us to identify cancer drugs
that will actually work in women and be
highly effective in curing breast cancer
you
you
you